- Which one are you gonna try first?
- I guess the one from Paris.
- Paris.
Me too.
I'm going the one.
I don't know what he said.
I can't remember.
- That's what he said.
- I want this right here.
I do have to ask you.
- Is this the fork?
- Look I don't know,
but it's a tiny spoon
and I don't really know
what to do with it.
I have to ask you,
what's your,
what's your favorite SNL character
that you've like ever played?
This is great.
- Favorite one that I played?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Well, I like doing the
ones with other people
'cuz I do like performing
with other people the most.
- [Kelly] Yeah a team.
- I think that's yeah.
Team playing was always fun.
Like there's a character named,
there was a,
a character called Azra La Bis,
that was a goth character
with Molly Shannon,
called, it was called Goth Talk
and I would go I'm Azra La Bis,
I'm the Prince of Sorrow.
I remember that,
anyone remember that audience?
A la audience on the a la rooftop?